(people crying)
- [Narrator] Thousands of Palestinians,
nearly half of them women
and children have been killed and injured
after a week of Israeli strikes on Gaza
according to officials in the enclave.
(airstrikes booming)
The attacks are Israel's response
to the assault by Hamas militants,
which killed over 1,400
Israelis on October 7th,
many of them women and children.
(Benjamin speaking in Hebrew)
On Friday, Israel demanded
people in Gaza City to evacuate
to the southern part of the enclave,
prompting fears of a
humanitarian disaster.
But as the Israeli forces turn
parts of Gaza into rubble,
the question is can Palestinian civilians
actually hide anywhere from the strikes?
The Gaza Strip is a sliver
of land bordering Israel
and Egypt, twice the
size of Washington, D.C.
With more than two million
people living there,
it is one of the most densely
populated places on Earth.
(airstrike booming)
Over the past week, nearly half
of the Strip's population
have fled their homes
according to the United Nations.
(Howida speaking in foreign language)
People have sought shelter
in UN-run schools,
hospitals, and local hotels,
many of which have been hit
by Israeli bombing according to the UN.
But hardly anyone could flee the enclave.
That is because Gaza has been
under blockade from both
Israel and Egypt since 2007
when Hamas seized to control of the area,
making it difficult to leave
Gaza even before the war.
A heavily fortified perimeter
called the Iron Wall
separates Gaza and Israel.
Normally, some people
could cross the border
at this crossing,
but not since the Hamas
militants raided it.
The border between Egypt
and Gaza is also fortified
with only one point to get
through at Rafah Crossing.
But Palestinians can't pass
it without a special permit
(people shouting)
and Israeli forces have bombed
the crossing several times
in recent days, making it
even more difficult to cross
for those who have permission,
according to local authorities,
Egyptian officials, and the UN.
With Israel's military having
ordered a total siege on Gaza,
supplies of food and fuel
are no longer reaching the enclave.
Getting aid via Egypt is also
complicated by the bombing
of the Rafah Crossing.
On Tuesday, trucks purportedly
carrying aid from Egypt
were forced to move back
to the Egyptian side of the border.
(airstrike booming)
As densely populated areas
of Gaza get relentlessly bombarded,
hospitals are struggling
with the number of injured.
(Mohammad speaking in foreign language)
With power running out in the Strip,
the hospitals are at risk
of turning into mass morgues
according to the International
Committee of the Red Cross.
The Israeli military said
that it has a reduced capacity
for precision strikes because
its forces are stretched thin.
Military officials haven't explained
why it attacked the Rafah border crossing
after the Israeli army
ordered Gazans to evacuate
to the southern part of the enclave
accusing Hamas of using
civilians as human shields.
Hamas told civilians
to stay in their homes.
But even as people go south,
the UN warns that such
mass movement will lead
to devastating humanitarian consequences.
(pensive music)